[Music]
[Applause]
senior nfl reporter lead content
strategist for the monday morning
quarterback albert let me start with
what we think
is the truth that adam schefter reported
on the night of the draft that
aaron rodgers once out of green bay
told the team that we haven't heard
anything i don't know if it's confirmed
by anybody but it's become
fact right has aaron rodgers has anybody
confirmed that aaron rodgers said to the
packers
i want out i mean i can tell you that
they've had
like numerous conversations over the
last few months
which has included trips to california
matt lafleur brian gouda comes to people
in charge in green bay
to try to eradicate the issue between
the team and the player
and and i think aaron rodgers like i've
said this to you all along i think dan
is that like we should listen to him we
should listen to him in january we
should listen to him
you know when he's said when he's
confirmed a lot of what he said
initially to pat mcafee
um you know and i don't think anything
that aaron rodgers does is a mistake
he's calculating
he's very intelligent he understands the
media like i i just
i failed to believe that any of this
stuff is by accident and so
um you know the packers are very well
aware that they've got a situation on
their hands that they've got to find a
way to fix
they got a team that's in a position to
win right now you look at the age of
their core
too a lot of guys that are smack dab in
the middle of their prime on big
contracts
um you know i i they're going to do
everything they can to try to get aaron
rodgers back in house
um there's an awareness there that
jordan loves not ready to go
and you know i i really think that um
you know like if you just watch the way
the packers have operated over the last
three four months
there's no question there's a very
serious problem there and you know i
think a big part of it is what aaron
wants which
you know it looks a lot like i think
what tom brady has now in tampa
but the trade discussions it doesn't
really
feel like there's any firmness to the
reporting on it it's
it's almost like we're wishful reporting
here or
we're wishful speculating well you know
what would denver have to offer what
about the raiders
yeah i i don't know what his market
value is i don't know if they've made an
offer has denver called green bay
has has you know the raiders have they
called green bay
i'm assuming everybody's called them um
now you know when i talked to
to brian gouda kunst on draft weekend
you know he said that he had just gotten
one call
on the day of the draft and that was it
and obviously john lynch acknowledged
that the niners made a phone call
so you can put two and two together on
that but i mean i would assume at the
very least
and i don't know this for a fact that
the broncos gm george payton picked up
the phone and called
that the raiders gm mike mayok picked up
the phone and called
if you see that aaron rodgers going to
be interested in you would be almost
irresponsible not to make those phone
calls and i think the other thing you
can look at here dan
is a lot of these teams have left their
options open
you know i mean denver and carolina
really like justin fields they wind up
passing on him their options
are open to go and get veteran
quarterbacks we see
you know miami i think still sitting out
there with a lot of capital
and i think maybe they'd be more in the
desean watson sweepstakes than the aaron
rodgers sweepstakes if these sweepstakes
ever happen um you know but there are
you know a number of teams out there
that have left their options open
and you know at this point like they i
think the aaron rodgers thing is where
the desean watson thing was three months
ago where
back then nick casario was getting phone
calls and giving everybody a flat no
the packers response to anyone calling
has been we're not trading aaron rodgers
we'll see if that changes over well
that's a dangerous game
that some of these teams played on draft
night that you
love that quarterback it's a young
quarterback
and you decide that hey we're not going
to take a quarterback that we think
could be our future
because we might be in the in the chase
for aaron rodgers
is that what you're saying i don't know
if it's just that i mean
like look for both denver and carolina
it was literally
the top defensive player in the draft in
their opinion
jc horn for carolina patrick certain
for denver versus going all in on justin
fields and if you take justin fields
then you're tied to him like your job
security if your matt rule your job
security
if you're vic fangio and george payton
it ties directly to those guys
to that guy if you draft him that high
but
i do think that a piece of it for both
those teams was
maintaining flexibility at the
quarterback position
knowing how quickly things have changed
at that position over the last six
months
and i think there's an acknowledgment
there too dan and this is league-wide i
mean if you talk to any general manager
they'll acknowledge this the like the
way
quarterbacks are being handled is
starting to change
and i think a huge part of that goes
back to tom brady and the way that the
bucks have built around tom brady and
the way the bucks have mortgaged
contracts
to win in a certain window as tom brady
and the fact that tom brady took the
risk of changing teams so late in his
career
and it worked and they won the super
bowl and so
you know i i think that there are some
teams that are looking at like the
landscape right now the nfl and saying
if these high-end quarterbacks are going
to be available if deshawn watson or
aaron rodgers
is going to be available over the next
four or five months
maybe we're best off taking a really
good player at the top of the draft
and keeping our options open at the most
important position but if i said
if you were going to i guess it's a
hunch and maybe that's not fair to you
who's the quarterback week one for the
packers
who's the quarterback week one for the
texans
the quarterback week one for the packers
i believe is going to be aaron rodgers
i think they'll find a way to fix it um
now that's gonna be complicated because
i think what aaron
wants like the ship sort of sailed on it
on that you know
i think what aaron wants is again like
the
the packers to build with the same sort
of urgency that the bucks have built
around
tom brady and you know i think it's yeah
like how do you do that now
right like free agency's over the
draft's over i i mean you're into
you're into the end of may like i mean
maybe you can trade for julio jones
um but what can you do other than make
promises to aaron rodgers
that we're gonna take the way that we've
done business for the last 30 years and
we're going to throw it out
starting in 2022. is that how you get
them back in
maybe it is you know but i think that
something like that
has to happen um and then the texans
like i think the likelihood right now is
that tyrod taylor's the starting
quarterback there
and i also think there's a likelihood
that deshaun watson's played his last
game as a texan
i think whenever you have whenever we
get clarity on the legal situation and
the league situation
yeah i do think houston is going to wind
up moving him and i'm not sure where
um but you know i i do know that the
tone in that building changed a whole
bunch
from january to the end of march into
april
you know i talked on my podcast to the
gm there nick casario and i gave him
you know a half dozen different chances
to say
you know desean watson is our
quarterback deshaun watson is going to
be our starter
and he wouldn't do it and that was a a
very marked change from where they had
been
even like three or four weeks before
that and so i think that there's a
likelihood that deshaun watson gets
moved whenever
the league and the legal system give us
clarity on all of where he stands
he's albert breer senior nfl reporter
lead content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback
i know you mentioned this yesterday
which is part of the reason why i wanted
to have you on that you know
don't count out miami with desean watson
it feels like that
has been the destination that he wants
and that's the quarterback they want
even though they have to atonga vialoa
so why do you think that that's still
a possibility he gives them a chance to
get a lot better at the most important
position on the field without blowing up
their what they've been doing for the
last three off seasons
um i i do know that you know
brian flores is confident in the culture
that he's built um
and the ability to absorb you know a
story like that
i think he feels like you know he he's
got the organization in a place where
um where they can do that and if you
look at the capital they've got
to offer houston think about this dan
like nick casario comes from new england
what college program is new england
closest to
closest to alabama right so you would
think that nick casario probably has
good information on tua so i think tua
in a miami houston deal could wind up
becoming a really interesting chip
where maybe nick casario looks at it and
says
we get two in here now we've got tua and
davis mills who we took in the third
round
throw them into a competition behind
tyrod taylor
maybe we have something a quarterback
then that can that that can you know
answer the question long term for us
and then miami has a first round pick
next year and two first round picks in
2023 to offer
so you add all of it up and with the
capital that they have
you just you could really offer
something enticing to houston
without completely blowing up what
you've been building for the last three
years and when you're talking about
trading for a player like a desean
watson and aaron rodgers
like in most cases you've got to
completely blow up your timeline
right like you've got a all right like
we're getting rid of all this draft
capital we're
going to build our team a different way
miami doesn't have to do that
miami's set up in a way where they could
go and get deshaun watts and give
houston something really good
and come out of it still sort of on the
same timeline they've been building on
for the last three years
uh urban meyer and his decisions that
he's made whether it's
bringing in the strength and
conditioning coach from iowa
and that didn't do well uh dr drafting a
running back
uh travis etienne and maybe making him a
wide receiver
now you have tim tebow here is there a
perception of urban meyer
that's forming in your opinion of just
what he's doing as a nfl coach as
opposed to a college coach
so like if you look at his staff there
are a lot of
nfl assistants right like a lot of guys
who
are plainly nfl coaches
uh now there are some guys like charlie
strong on the staff that go back with
him but there's
you know chris ash you know um but there
are like guys that are
you know like daryl bevel like brian
schottenheimer like joe cullen that are
strictly nfl assistants
i i think what you look at when you see
some of the moves you're talking about
is maybe urban is going to adjust some
but he's also going to bring a lot of
what he already was
at the college level with him and i
think the proper comparison for travis
etienne if you want to really look at it
is percy harvin at florida or curtis
samuel at ohio state like that's
what i think they envisioned travis
etienne being and it also explains why
you take etienne even though you've got
james robinson
and uh and carlos hyde at tailback
already
so like you see him in sort of that
h-back role then go over to tebow
what's tebow well if you look at what
urban meyer became the last few years at
ohio state
really he's more of a culture coach than
anything else he's a program builder
and what do coaches like that do well
they value guys who can sell
what they're bringing into a program in
the locker room
and tim tebow can do that over the next
three or four months for urban meyer so
maybe he makes it maybe he doesn't
but at the very least he's got a guy who
you know has some name recognition in
the locker room
who can help urban try to sell the
program that he's bringing to the nfl
and so
i think when you add those things up dan
i think you see
you know while urban is willing to bend
some you know and that shows in all the
nfl assistants he's brought in
he's also got his own ideas that have
worked for him for the last 20 years
that are absolutely coming with him why
is tebow so polarizing to people
um it's it's fascinating because
i don't even know how to answer this dan
i like it it's it's weird right like but
i i think a big part of it is
he was on the front end of playing
quarterback in a different way
right and he was sort of on the front
end of the nfl game changing to adjust
to allow quarterbacks like this to play
in the league
um you know and around the same time
that like a cam newton came into the nfl
a robert griffin the third came in the
nfl
now all of a sudden like your tommy
fraziers and your scott frost
from 30 years ago were getting a shot in
the league
and so you had this guy coming from
florida who
didn't really look like he could play
the quarterback position in a
conventional manner
but was such an a plus guy from an
intangible standpoint
and had such a large following and
there's the religious thing
and so i just think he became polarizing
because he was so popular
with a certain group of people that
automatically that's going to make you
sort of
another group of people sort of
skeptical of of who you are
as a player and i like i probably just
did a horrible job of explaining that to
you
because there's so much there you know
what i mean but
i like it's weird right like i i'll give
you this
i went back and so i talked with john
fox
a couple days ago about about tebow as a
tight end
and he brought to light to me said like
well you know we actually put him in a
game as a tight end and i didn't even
remember
remember this at all his second game in
denver john fox's second game in timber
they put him in the game at tight end
and he played three plays and foxy said
to me he's like yeah like you know like
he looked functional out there
so i went back in my game pass and i
looked it up you know the first thing i
noticed about it dan
was was when he came on the field
the crowd had been quiet right and it
popped
and it was unbelievable and here's a guy
coming in in an emergency situation
and like he like he's wearing receiver
gloves you know and he's wearing elbow
pads
it's like i like i almost forget how red
how just insane that story was so
uh that's like i said i've done a
horrific job of answering that question
for you but it's hard to explain right
like you just know it when you see it
but it's
it's gimmicky but then there's so many
things in life that are gimmicky
you know i go like this uh
guy fighting floyd mayweather you know
jake
paul or whatever logan paul like he's
nobody
but it's a gimmick and he gets a chance
to get in the ring with one of the great
fighters of all time and make millions
of dollars
uh you know we we take chances give
chances
we do favors all this is just the 90-man
roster
and i'm going if a guy is going to lose
his
roster spot on the 90-man roster
then he deserves to have it in jeopardy
if you tebow comes in and takes it from
you
right and i i guess i immediately when
you when you brought all that stuff up i
immediately thought for some reason
about chad johnson racing the horse
um well dk metcalf they gave him a spot
to run in that race yeah yeah
yeah so i i think it's but but you know
what like like
now that you mention it it's like kind
of i guess what we're talking about is
seeing something that seems absurd on
its face right
and that whole thing was absurd like you
remember that bears game
right like where like the the ball goes
out of bat like it's just like the
weirdest stuff was happening and it was
unexplainable
and it's sort of like backed up like
this guy like there's just something
intangibly
intangible about this guy that like you
can't explain it and it may look like
crap
but somehow at the end of the day at the
end of the game you look up at the
scoreboard
and his team has more points than the
other team right
and so like it was just like i guess
that's what it is it's like
we we all witnessed something that was
so like just on its face absurd
in 2011 and maybe like in the back of
our heads
we're all wondering if some version of
that could play out again
10 years later in 2021 that's the best
way to explain it i guess
right i mean the guy almost the guy i
almost made the 40-man roster with the
mets and he hadn't played
baseball since high school i like he's
like the real-life forrest gump
but you know what i mean but that's
gimmicky as well and they they used him
and he used them so there was
reciprocation there
yeah and and you know maybe
jacksonville's doing that that hey
come on in i mean imagine when he goes
into a game
in jacksonville in his hometown he'll
get a bigger roar than trevor lawrence
will
i mean that's the other thing 90 minutes
from gainesville i think right
like i mean like maybe this wouldn't be
a circus in kansas city
but in jacksonville where like everyone
who covers the gators
can just get in their car and drive over
right like
i mean that's the thing about it like
that's that to me is what's so
interesting about this calculation for
urban meyer
is like it'd be one thing if he was
bringing in a guy
who was maybe a good player for him at
florida or ohio state and has like a
nominal chance of making the roster
right but the stuff that you're inviting
in with
tim which and again like this isn't even
his fault it just comes with him
like the circus that you're bringing
with him and then the other players
constantly having to
answer questions about it like i i think
the real
risk here and this this part's
interesting to me
like i think the real risk here for
urban is
does it chip away at your credibility at
all like if you're bringing him
in and you're asking the team to accept
him as a nfl tight end right
and it just looks awful and then you
hang on
like so like let's say we get to
training camp and it looks terrible the
first
three days of camp right and remember
tebow like didn't look good
in practice at quarterback in denver so
like let's say like it just doesn't look
right the first three or four days
does urban have to get rid of him right
because the guy's not on scholarship
like does urban have to get rid of him
imagine cutting him right like like so
like at that point like do you get rid
of him or and if you hang on to him for
another couple weeks
does that chip await your credibility
because there are other guys trying to
make the team there
right that are looking at it and saying
to themselves
well wait a minute like this guy like
what is this like
why is this happening over here the
guy's i mean and it's not like he's 23
years old it's not like you're
projecting three years into the future
you know what i mean like
like what's the what's the real upside
here the guy's not gonna become tony
gonzalez at least i don't think so
no he's not um you know like so that's
the thing about it like that
the credibility part of it i think is
really interesting because
urban takes that stuff so seriously you
know what i mean like
having credibility with his players and
and that's why so many of his guys
believe in him so deeply
is because he's brought such credibility
to the table and everything that he does
and that's what's so interesting you
sort of wonder like what's the plan
for him and does urban just have a blind
spot for this guy or is there something
more to it
great to talk to you albert thanks we
appreciate your time all right great to
talk to you again that's albert breer
the monday morning quarterback play of
the day's up next